[Music]
that's
refreshing all
right hope people are doing all right
this evening evening where I am who
knows what time it is where you are um
no particular uh topic tonight uh hope
folks had a good Labor Day weekend if
you're in the US I don't know if any
other countries celebrate Labor Day I
think it's us specific I don't
know I never remember these
things no Peter my my hair is in fact
rapidly losing its color because I
haven't had it refreshed in
months so no I have not colored my hair
I have failed to color my hair is what
you are you are currently seeing you
have Labor Day in Canada too okay Peter
but is it the same day because I know
like your Thanksgiving is way off in its
own place
so yes it did Miss Wicked
Wolf um so I hope everyone is doing well
reminder I will try to keep up with the
chat as best I can however the only
thing that will guarantee that I'm able
to get your question or that I see it is
to do it with the Super Chat which will
also get you a heart from me um I will
try and keep up with the chat otherwise
but you
know no
promises no Miz Wicked Wolf I am not I
can't remember the last time I drank
enough to actually be tipsy on
stream it's been been a while I think it
might have been the first helped me pay
my tax bill
stream like two and a half years
ago it's been a while I have not it's
been a while since I've done a drunk
review it's been a while since I've had
more than a single drink on stream I
don't really do it too much these days I
haven't had a reason I think is the
thing it's not that like oh I don't
drink anymore yes I do um but it's
rather it's it's a case of uh
you know I feel like I need an occasion
not just going to do it I think most
other places have their equivalent of
Labor Day on the 1 of May ah
interesting I'm pretty tired and had a
bit of a hard week but all in all I
can't complain which I just realized a
very very German answer to give and
that's that's always a phrase that
always kind of would make me tell my
head I can't complain sure you can we
can all complain maybe you've decided
nobody wants to hear it but sure you
can I would super chat but I'm broke I
understand Ash boy do I understand we
had some kind of holiday in Taiwan
Sunday was Armed Forces Day and also we
had a typhoon oh well that's nice Mother
Nature wanted to
celebrate today's Michael Keaton's 72nd
birthday he looks good for his age which
song is better walking on the son or
Allstar H yeah
Smashmouth um Allstar is a better song
them walking on the
sun I was going to say May 1st is a
popular labor recogn recognition day
around the world I wasn't sure if that
was it or not oh
okay how about you do a stream when
you're high
I I have
gotten Buzz bued in that
fashion once in the
last decade
about
um I
just basically like somebody had half of
a brownie and they were like do you want
the other half I was like screw it I
guess and it's like um not sure I missed
this it's not awful but I that I would
not do on stream cuz I don't think it
would be
entertaining I think me drinking can be
entertaining at least I hope so I've
done multiple videos while
drunk but that other kind of buzz I
don't think I'd be I don't think I'd be
very fun I would lose
track of my thoughts and I I would keep
stopping mids sentence and I wouldn't
have control of the volume of my voice I
don't think it'd be a good
time just came back from monthlong
holiday in Tanzania around two days ago
lovely hope you had a good time Mr Zacky
boy back with my candle dressed with
olive oil and some cinnamon for luck and
an Wisconsin oldfashioned
now that first sentence Pirates okay
back with my candle dressed with olive
oil and some cinnamon for luck I'm
assuming it's the candle that's dressed
with olive oil and some cinnamon because
I feel like that sentence could be read
that you're back with your candle and
it's you who are dressed in some olive
oil and a little cinnamon you know for
luck H do I have a hooded blanket no I
do
not
H I saw on YouTube that in India was
Teachers Appreciation Day oh well good
on
them I Dharma I describe myself as a as
a goofy
drunk um I just get
silly uh your title is quite fitting I
had apple cider mixed with ginger beer
oh I have a
lovely uh blueberry apple
cider thanks for your podcast I finally
bit the bullet and started the prison
has been on my radar for some time well
I hope you enjoy it Jedi um I know Jesse
definitely
is uh yes the candle is dressed with the
olive oil okay look I'm just you know
some things were open to
interpretation I know it's a little
early but what was your favorite
Halloween costume that you wore that you
ever
[Music]
wor I have no idea
probably the Dracula
costume when I was a kid I don't know
though like I don't have like oh this
one costume that time I don't I don't
know was a ninja one year is that
cultural appropriation it might have
been I don't
know I doubt that's apple cider it is
absolutely apple cider made by uh an
apple cider
company that
makes hard apple
cider someone once told me to do a show
in cons and they started throwing some
bread feel like that's a reference that
I don't
know uh I don't drink but people
jokingly tell me that I should get drunk
to become less High Strung and weird
that's not how getting drunk
works it might I mean alcohol is a
depressant but
um it's not going to turn you into a
different person it's actually more
liable to
accentuate uh the kind of person that
you are inherently have I tried me
before not only have I tried me um I had
an acquaintance well I still have the
acquaintance but she no longer does this
who made me me and she made amazing meat
and she stopped because it was a side
gig for her and she didn't have the time
anymore it's a shame there's another
meery in Vermont called artisano which
isn't bad but I liked her stuff better
she made meat in her garage it was
really good I've been obsessed with we
are all pawns I love that show so much
oh thank you Louise I hope you enjoy it
we'll see uh if the strike's still going
on when we
finish maybe for Halloween this year you
got as a sexy tick Tik Tok
influencer that's my everyday
costume it's flu season yeah every
year uh someone threw bread at
Smashmouth once Harwell threatened to
beat the guy up to the allstar
instrumental wow oh
goodness homemade me seems to be the
trick I've heard yeah like she I think
I've still got some but like it's the
last bottle I'm ever going to get to
have but like she has a mold Mead like
that in warmed up apple cider like
normal cider it oh it's so good ah gonna
miss
it ah you got a friend who brews I like
the idea of me because I like
bees H one of the best recordings of it
had someone in the crowd you Ki his ass
sea
baths
oh good
grief uh reminds me of a line from The
Adams Family oh from Wednesday oh but
sweetheart where's your costume this is
my costume I'm a homicidal maniac they
look just like everyone
else oh
Wednesday the best me I ever had was a
local blank called fre kiss good name
good title there's unfortunately one of
the bigger meeries uh in the state I
really don't like their stuff very much
I'm not going to name them because you
know it's other people's jam and I don't
want to badmouth a local business but
like other than
um sticky Paws which was the the one uh
the person I knew who did out of out of
her garage which is now gone there's
artisano uh in the middle of the state
they're pretty good they're pretty good
and there's another one that I'm not
going to name
that I like their Vibe I like their
energy a lot I don't love their ma
though it's a
shame I always support small businesses
I mean you know unless it's run by an
[__] not that the the metery that I'm
not naming uh is if it was I might
actually name and say don't buy from
them the uh the owners are [__] but
that's that's not the
um that's not the case with them I just
don't particularly like the product mold
cider so good so nice War yeah yeah
we're getting into the season
unfortunately we're in the middle of a
heat wave
here uh official temperature has been in
the 80s but like with the sun beating
down like it's crept up to 100 and it's
got godd damn September and it's not
okay it's not
okay highly recommend putting
marshmallow fluff in hot cider to those
who like things sweet that might be a
little bit too much for me because I I
like the tartness of a good cider like
there's a little sweet Magner cider
here's the funny thing about Magner
cider Pirates I it was the first cider I
ever had so I'm to algic for it I don't
super love it though now at this point
because I found so much stuff that I
like a lot
more I'll agree with that caroan fluff
is very good for hot
chocolate love your videos I really
value your opinion oh thank you Bray I
appreciate
that uh you know the podcast I was
anxious was mad at me he put out a Q&A
with a physicist and when he got to my
questions he reacted to me like he
always has it's GCU Problem Child fun
yeah like
the I'll keep saying
it podcasters
YouTubers they have no reason to hold a
grudge you have to go way out of your
way and honestly at that point if they
truly held a grudge they would block you
or ignore you um
so uh would would I ever do another AP
series aside from quill and sword um so
for folks who don't know AP being actual
play so like a D and D campaign um I
know uh Stephen is has started working
on what will be the next campaign we do
afterwards which will be a completely
different thing so uh technically yes
I'm already making plans too because I I
want to keep working with that same
group I don't know if he's going to
change the name of it he might because
quillin Sor won't really fit the
aesthetic of what he's building for the
new thing but that's getting ahead of
things Supreme Omega thank you so very
much for the Super Chat greatly
appreciated ever since the 2000s
thoughts on comic writers constantly
trying to tear down Batman inide the bat
family Ray acts manipulative and
paranoid
h i mean there's just there's just way
too much emphasis on Batman and there
has been for a long time in DC it's like
they forget they
have other
characters half the
time
so I don't have a problem with the
general conceit of tension among the
members of the bat family that being
said that should be a rarity not a go-to
plotline I think Batman's paranoia works
better when it is focused outside of his
inner circle I think it makes sense
that he has a certain amount of paranoia
about all the people with superpowers
who if they wanted to could snap him in
half in a heartbeat if they really felt
like it even though some of them are his
friends I think he is the kind of person
that it is understandable he has a
certain amount of paranoia and there's a
certain amount of inherent tension even
amongst the friendships I think he
should be on much more solid footings
with the bat family I mean part of this
is they keep traumatizing members of the
bat family
because I don't know because Bruce is
traumatized and so they've decided
everybody needs to be traumatized and
let's kill Tim Drake's dad who was
supportive and let's completely mess up
Cassandra Kane from top to bottom
and I don't
know they can't seem to come up I mean
this is true beyond the bat family a lot
of comics these days really can't seem
to come up uh at least the the from the
big two a more original idea than let's
traumatize our characters
again the thing
is and this is the
inherent
problem they don't see the contradiction
in the fact that the moments that
readers really remember are often
moments that are traumatic for the
characters the death of Gwen
Stacy Batman getting his back broken the
death of Jason
Todd um Superman dying like these are
traumatic events and they are memorable
events but part of the reason that
they're memorable is because they are
the exception not the rule if you have
birthday cake every single night for
dessert it's not special anymore it's
only special because you have it once a
year on your damn
birthday so they recognize like o people
really take to and remember and talk
about the the traumatic events so we'll
just do all these traumatic events all
the time and everyone will love it no
they won't because it's not special
anymore yeah and that's a problem I I
want to I want to blame the editorial
level for that I really do but the
problem is there are legitimately lots
of comic writers who seem to not get
this Tom
[Music]
King watching uh darku series 7B at the
moment clar is working for me but man is
rings of acatan sap I know some people
really like that
one I'm not going to talk about
it when everyone is super no one will be
I mean I don't like to use that line
because it's the freaking villain and
people have like tried
to offer that as like a legitimate point
of view it's like there's a reason it's
the villain who says
that and the anime about anime I'm
watching the Cliffhanger in the episode
I just watch is that the original manga
artist tried to veto the last episode at
the uh at the last minute should artists
be able to do that I
[Music]
mean short version no not by default if
you've signed off on an adaptation of
your
work then you are signing off on
relinquishing some control of how it's
going to take shape now maybe they want
to include you maybe they
don't um and if they do want to include
you and you want to be included that's
great but you know you assuming that
we're not in a force gum situation where
you just flat out got screwed out of
your
paycheck assuming that that is not the
case and everything is above board and
you've been properly compensated for the
rights to adapt your
work no
if you're not directly involved in that
production no you have no business
vetoing anything especially if they're
not
asking has anyone seen the new Toho
Godzilla trailer looks awesome it's a
remake of the original I did see that I
feel like they're they're going back to
they've been going back to the um oh
it's like the very first time Godzilla
comes out thing for a while like that's
what Shin Godzilla was I feel like
they've been doing that a
bit what do I think of the fact Fast and
Furious series believe it or
not I have never seen a fast and furious
movie all the way
through I've been on a binge of all the
Saw movies for the first time you are on
your own on that one only one left to go
they get really shut your brain off
movies but they are really great shut
your brain off movies but also
surprisingly puzzle boxy I mean like
they're they're movies that I've enjoyed
hearing other people talk about I only
ever saw the first one I'm like this is
okay I do not need to see the
rest speaking of being jerked around
Mary Jane's really been put through the
rare oh good grief
yes the problem with Disney villains is
that the older I get the more I realize
they kind of have a point depends on the
villain regardless if you're going
classic Disney villains they're often
more
fun uh
uh Captain Lunar thank you very much for
the Super Chat greatly appreciated
Marvel's Thor from the comics with the
Shakespeare lingo and all is real how
does the world
change um I'm not entirely sure I follow
the
question I'm
yeah no I'm sorry Captain Lunar you
stumped me I I don't understand what
you're
asking when I went to see The Little
Mermaid my friend's son saw the most
recent fast and fies and wasn't
impressed we were like well what did you
expect I mean those do seem like you get
what you pay for kind of
movies uh it made me wonder if that was
a creative conceit if that's how anime
adaptations actually work like I find it
hard to believe it's the latter given
hyper capitalist Japan I don't I don't
know enough about I don't know enough
about Japanese culture in general and I
definitely don't know enough about the
inner workings of manga anime and the
crossover between the two um so I I will
have no opinion on
that
H I've only seen a Godzilla movie once
and funnily enough that was one of those
that was at one of those adult birthday
parties that your parents take take you
to with them at one point all the kids
were gathered in the master bedroom on
the queensize bed and doing random
things while Godzilla was on the TV in
the
background I yeah no I didn't really get
dragged to those I was a latch key kid I
was trusted not to burn down the
house
ah saw hunted Mansion I forgot that came
out uh not only am I going to be
reviewing good omen SE season 2 that
will be Saturday's video I just shot it
earlier
today um so uh saw Haunted Mansion the
villain's name was Crump the
screenwriter previously wrote the 2016
Ghostbusters in which the villain was
called Rowan what have I done to her I'm
so sorry Rowan apparently you have a
villain his name I don't know what to
tell you Captain Lunar back with a
clarification basically what if Thor as
he is in the com okay what if Thor as he
is in the comics was real and acted as a
superhero while being a real God what
changes so like in the real
world
um it
everything like let let's be very
serious if somebody
exhibited the powers of Thor in real
life and like in a demonstrably provable
real way not a trick not CGI not an
after effect not an illusion but really
tangible real it would change freaking
everything
everybody basically everybody except um
certain Stripes of still practicing
pagans would have a freaking meltdown
for one reason or
another
so sorry I'm getting texted why am I
getting texted
H all right I need to deal with that
after I loved your rant on the on the
ninja turs crushing on
April they gotta stop
that they gotta stop
that hey there ver it's my 22nd birthday
next Wednesday can you wish me a happy
birthday also so I am finally saddling
in this whole thing in this whole being
in college away from my parents thing
well anelise happy birthday and I wish
you the best of luck in college may your
college career be more successful than
mine was did you ever watch Jurassic
world Dominion I did not Louise I have
not seen that
one with all the discussion over the
years of being hot for
Monsters
even if it's just one class like
vampires what kind of monster have you
ever found attractive I mean top of that
list is Tim Curry and Legend as darkness
and yes I think he counts as a monster
he's like in the universe he's like
eight or nine feet tall and he's got
he's got cloven Hooves and massive horns
he's a monster um but but if we're if
we're going like for
broader
types I don't know I kind I just kind of
dig fawns
honestly yeah I'm here for
fawns one thing about living in Santa
Clara I never go to stomach all the damn
vampires yeah Lost Boys reference I know
that
one um my favorite part of good omen 2
was growly drunk on Lum that was fun I
enjoyed that
uh do I sound like a
goat uh wait what was College like for
you now I'm concerned I I didn't finish
uh analy and it had nothing to do with
college experience it had to do with
me um falling off my meds and having a
personal life
meltdown uh and not going to class
so the reason I didn't finish college
had nothing to do with college and
everything to do with
me having uh seen some of qu and sword I
need to catch up your answer of fun is
especially amusing to me coincidental I
promise
uh what's the most overrated comedy
you've ever watched I don't
know literally everything just Apatow
ever
directed what TTR RPGs have you ever
played or at least caught your eye
tickled your fancy outside of that one
big one I have played call of cthulu
I've played the more recent um Star Wars
ttrpg uh since Disney took
over um because there was an older one I
never played that but they they redid it
I've played a Transformers
ttrpg that was interesting um those are
the main ones that I think I've done the
rest of it's been you know the big
one is Darkness from from Legend
daddy that's your own call if you
believe that to be
so I didn't finish college because I
struggled and lost confidence try and
get in my 40s and it's going much better
I'm very glad to hear that pirates
um let's see is there an episode of The
Prisoner you especially excited to see
Jesse's reaction to I mean I'm gonna be
damn curious to
see what the hell she makes of the
finale I'll tell you that one for
free uh and not just for like the reason
that everyone has fought over for the
last um 60 years years or so um even
stuff before that I'm going to be very
curious to see uh her reaction and
thoughts
about so we'll
see
uh let me see
here YouTube recently put up Zoolander
for free and yeast some lines and scenes
there of age like milk I mean comedy
ages the worst I think of any genres
kind of by its
nature um not all comedies but broadly
speaking as a genre it tends to age
badly the uh do ADHD Dr and the fact
that I may or may not be bisexual either
that or I have a bad case of uh straight
not blind is what drew me to your
channel well I'm very glad to have you
here in Elise I greatly appreciate that
love your top never seen it all before
Oh see if we can actually get it on on
camera and uh enjoy the
view has dumb and dum aged well I don't
know I'm not going to rewatch it to find
out not unless somebody pays
me Center for ants is still brilliant
though see here's the joke that I like
from
Zoolander um is when he asks
um David Duvy um but why male models and
David duy gives this whole explanation
you know you just you do what you're
told and you don't think and then Zander
still looking at him but why male
models and apparently that wasn't even
scripted Stiller forgot his next line so
he just repeated
it even bad comedies can have good jokes
somewhere in
there uh
uh you know uh
when hold on what you you know when me
and came over we I can't follow this
question
uh okay I'm I'm not sure I followed that
uh 255
dumb D two exists believe it or not I'm
aware Discord yes thank you Carolyn with
the strikes going on is watching
reaction videos of uh of applicable
media supporting the studio so
Christopher I actually answered that in
text way way back um before the stream
started but I'll reiterate it here so
here's the thing and then I'm going to
go jump over the Discord and then
Captain Lunar I will come back and
address that Super Chat here's the thing
uh Christopher the unions are not asking
consumers to alter their viewing habits
or behavior in any way shape or form
they are not calling for any kind of
consume excuse me consumer boycott of
any media at all what they are doing is
they have asked influencers who wish to
support the strike to refrain from
engaging in reaction content
specifically review is okay analysis is
okay they're asking influencers to not
do reaction content because that very
much feeds into the promotional end of
things and it's not critique or
review now if you want to make a call
that somebody continuing to do that kind
of content makes you uncomfortable you
don't want to see it that's your own
call to make but the unions are not
asking you as a viewer and consumer to
do that they have made a request of
influencers which influence influencers
are not bound
by they're not it is a
request so people have made their own
call some people continue to make that
sort of content for uh hopefully for
whatever reasons they feel it is
Justified or make sense but you know
that's that's
it uh and anyways so let me pull up the
Discord oh we've only got one set of
questions so this shouldn't take too
long in Oppenheimer a major uh plot
point is oppenheimer's communist
sympathies and how people use them
through his career in the 50s something
I wondered after I saw the film is could
you have made a somewhat sympathetic
movie about a guy who had communist
sympathies 35 years ago I.E before the
end of the Cold War or would you have to
admit that part oh they would have
glossed over it like hell they wouldn't
have touched it with a with a 10- foot
pole um or if they did they would have
framed it as a um you know he was
treated as guilty because of
associations and whoops he made he made
a mistake and he paid for it they
wouldn't frame it like um he was
persecuted for his beled they would
frame it as whoops he made a mistake and
it bit him so that's probably how it
would be framed 35 years ago if they
touched it at all odds are they
wouldn't um I don't even think it's it's
a matter of um you know could somebody
have made that like nobody would think
to not with a major Studio release not
at that
time uh the anime about making anime
that I'm watching one of the characters
this is a CG artist who gets frustrated
because the company she works for
gets known for creating the cars in
racing game cutscenes but she's
constantly just creating CG cars I never
know whether to feel sorry for artists
who get stuck doing repetitive work
because it's profitable for the
capitalists above them on the one hand I
imagine it's kind of Soul destroying for
uh someone who wants to create diverse
art on the other hand most people do
repetitive jobs under capitalism like I
imagine her job is at least more
stimulating than like being an Olive
Garden waiter so why should I feel bad
for the real people in her situation do
I feel bad for constrained creative
people short answer yes I do I always
will um
like I I feel like it's a very odd way
to ask the question like why should I
feel bad for them like in my mind you
either sympathize with or feel bad for
someone's position or you
don't and like if you want to examine
why you do or don't that's your
prerogative to figure out um so here's
the thing that I would that I would tell
you to keep in mind speaking as a
creative and having friends including
one who worked in the video game
industry who was very talented and
basically just had to spend years just
designing cloth textures and like fabric
physics that's all she got to do here's
the
thing I can understand why you would
think well it's closer to your passion
than like some other mindless job that's
completely separ separate so it must be
better not necessarily maybe but not
necessarily and here's
why because it can grind you down and
burn you out on the thing that you love
doing because if your passion is design
and 3D art and you have to use those
skills to make cars day in day out week
after week month after month year after
year and you don't get to do anything
else and it becomes a grind and it
grinds you down it's not just that
you've spent an exhausting day at work
you've spent an exhausting day doing
something that you would otherwise love
and then when you get home you're not
going to want to do it you're not going
to want to sit down and work with 3D
creation tools to try and do something
you actually want because you're not
just burning out on the repetitiveness
you're burning out on the process you're
burning out on the
activity it's really diff difficult for
something that is a core part of
something you love to become a Daily
Grind and for you to still be able to
continue to love that thing and continue
to love doing it so yeah I I will always
feel bad for Creative people putting
those
positions because you know you can think
well you know you're working in the
field that you want like are they though
because I don't think any of them wanted
to do that just because it's utilizing
the skills that they have passion for
doesn't mean that they're doing the job
that they want to do or are doing
anything that enables that passion in
any
way uh with regard to that same show
something I kind of don't like but uh
about it is that it depicts a toxic word
culture that is apparently common in
Japan and pretty bad in the anime
industry in particular Without Really
commenting on it like a couple of times
you see staff uh sleeping in their
offices because they're in Crunch and
the show's giving no indication uh
that's not a a thing workers shouldn't
be expected to do do you think it's
wrong for a work to depict a toxic work
culture without condemning it or really
ever commenting on it not necessarily it
depends on how far a field from the
story actually being told addressing
those things would be because depending
on the nature of the story they're
actually telling having those as
background details might be the extent
to which it makes sense to acknowledge
it at all
um so you know to take
um uh no I'm trying to avoid citing
examples cuz like a live stream isn't
really an analytical work so I really
shouldn't um but anyways like in in
general if if if a piece of fiction for
instance hypothetical imagined piece of
fiction had a character who was
effectively a
cop and who would R
routinely kind of fall into a lot of the
problems of real life policing of taking
advantage of his position
of intimidation Etc and if the show
depicted accurately but never properly
addressed it as being a bad thing is
that ideal no but if that's not the
overall main point of the thing and so
long as the show isn't going this is
good actually then I'm not going to get
mad about it I might get slightly
disappointed uh at a show like what you
described not addressing the work
culture but the fact that it's in there
at all is something they're not
pretending that it's not the case and
from what you described they're not
going this is good actually those would
be the things that I would think are
actually a legitimately Pro are a
legitimate problem and have actual moral
implications if you depict it as an
idealized workplace when it's just not
or if you more accurately depict what's
wrong with it but act like it's a good
thing see a certain episode of Doctor
Who series 11 with an Amazon knockoff um
yeah then you've actually run into a
problem but you're not obligated to give
full commentary on everything that is
present in your work cuz there aren't
enough hours in the day so there you go
all right I'm back I'm back baby Captain
Lunar back with the Super Chat thank you
so much ever heard of Captain space
defender of Earth Trope the basics is a
distilled Space Opera hero in the mold
of Flash Gordon or Buck Rogers one of my
favorite character tropes um I don't
think I'd heard that
particular name for the Trope but I know
I know the archetype I know the kind of
character
um they can be fun they can be fun I
mean
it's it's basically Buzz Lightyear when
he doesn't realize he's a toy is that
character uh I mean a parody of that
character but still Supreme
Omega here we go since you watched more
of Babylon 5 thoughts on the show
overall any aspects youd like and
aspects you just like do you prefer
Sinclair or
Sheridan I can't really talk about it
because this isn't a review or analysis
so I really
don't don't really have a ton of wiggle
room and I'm trying to avoid I know I
haven't been perfect on this um in terms
of avoiding talking about these things
on streams but I am trying to be better
about that while the strike is going
on um but you know uh what I will say is
there is a show that I have done a
podcast on and that podcast is not
finished and I think that show is very
well constructed there are many aspects
I like that at this point in time I will
not name in particular and I think on
balance I prefer the second lead in the
uh main role to the first but not by a
significantly heavy margin and possibly
simply because I got to spend more time
with him do I watch unboxing videos no I
really don't find them interesting at
all is Holy Terror still my favorite
Robert Sherman story it is it is I
haven't gotten to too many others of him
in the last couple years but what are
some of your favorite graphic novels if
you've read much of them uh
so some of these I have not
reread
so um I am
not I I'm not necessarily going to vouch
for how well some of these have
aged um but I like I enjoy um Sandman a
lot I like transmetropolitan a lot or at
least I did when I read it about a
decade ago that's one of the ones I'm
afraid to find out has aged badly um
for more recent well I mean I love neona
um and that's even from before the movie
of the more recent stuff there's one
called Snapdragon that I really like and
there's one called um The Prince and the
dress maker that
is beautiful that that graphic novel is
amazing it is so good it is so
good I missed out the word friends I was
saying we used to pretend
um that the bedrooms in my house were
military bases we pretend the mirrors
were computer screens uh that could lock
the other kids out but if they actually
got in they'd pretend to hack them oh
that's cute that's sweet BBC has been
repeating both I Claudius and the 1980
Oppenheimer series with Sam Waton oh I
imagine the Oppenheimer one's very
timely somebody asked earlier had have I
seen Oppenheimer nope I have not don't
really plan to to be honest Erica oh
geez very generous thank you very very
much Erica it's been a while since I've
been able to join a live stream so I
need to celebrate with a super chat a
thank you thanks for all thanks always
for the great content happy Tuesday and
a very happy Tuesday to
you do I watch makeup tutorials nope I
find them
dull partly because I know I'm never
going to do it what's the secret of
skipping rocks can never get the hang of
it um finding the right Rock um getting
low so that you're you're closer to
being parallel with the water and from
there it's all in the
wrist
practice do I have a vanity uh I do but
it's in the Attic you go back to a
several years old videos on the ver wild
Channel and you can see the thing but
not one that I actually
use don't worry we have poppenheimer at
home literally the
[Laughter]
BBC ah very
good very
good I still talk my plush animals in
bed a that's very sweet have I seen the
Meg and do I like shark movies I mean I
like Jaws I've not seen the Meg um I saw
a deep blue sea that was dumb but it was
fun um I don't super love shark movies
as a genre I just like the original Jaws
it's really good so it's just a really
good
movie do you prefer skimming rocks where
the aim is distance or skipping them
where the a is how many bounces do you
get I tend to focus on skip rather than
skim although um if you you know can do
it right you can achieve
both I really I just really need to get
off my chest that I absolutely love your
collection of glasses and glass of
friend oh thank you
Michael I appreciate
that I haven't gotten any new ones in a
little while but I like what I
have my rock skipping records is 14
skips I don't think I'll ever do that
again but I've gotten over 10 many times
I don't know what actually my number is
because I don't I don't fixate on it
even though I like I just I just like
being in the
moment it's just nice it's just
nice as a D and D fan and uh few years
on several of us here I must ask the
Animated Series yay or nay I am aware
that it exists I have never seen
it
so
ah I don't know do I still have any toys
from my childhood yeah a few
do I think Barbie will do more movies
after the success of it I don't know I
think Warner Brothers will
gravel um at the feet of the stars and
probably also Greta Gerwig um trying to
get them back to do more but they were
not contracted for sequels initially so
whether or not that happens I have no
idea I no doubt Warner Brothers and
Mattel will W more especially after the
freaking Polly Pocket movie either f to
happen at all or comes out and everyone
goes what the hell is
this I cannot believe they hired
Lena Dunham for
the moving on moving on Eric guess
message retracted thank you for the
Super Chat all the same I do still
appreciate it just as
much
ah
uh you like superhero stuff right yeah
for the most part what do you think of
my Adventures of Superman
I have not seen it so I have no opinion
sorry am I crazy and or alone in wanting
a reboot of the crow franchise and
wanting a new adaptation on screen I
probably not if you're asking if I'm in
that same
camp um no I don't really I
the crow is very much a product of its
time and I don't think it's going to
capture I don't think anything is going
to capture the moment as well as the
existing movie did you know you can have
your quibbles about it being more or
less uh true to the uh original work but
ultimately it just it just captured the
moment so perfectly because it was was
they were both of the time I just don't
I just don't think you can get that
again you know the thing with that
podcast where I was so anxious for like
an hour then he got to me and said now
it's time for the GCU Problem Child
section then laugh see it's fine it's
relaxed don't worry about it to the best
of your ability I understand we can't
help what we get anxiety
over bogey fan 101
do you think WB will ever
drop
um Voldemort woman
um I
think
that if
the Harry Potter series adaptations of
the books fail to do what WB needs them
to do I think they will let the rights
lapse
um especially especially if it costs so
much that they don't even finish uh all
the
books or if they cram several books
together into a season to finish it
quicker um any situation like that they
will let the rights lapse because the
movies were a um diminishing returns it
is my expectation that the T show will
be diminishing returns at best and by
the time they're done they're going to
be breaking even at best and I think
they will do what they did with Lego
which is
go we ran this for as long as we could
it's kind of gone it's kind of dead now
in terms of Returns versus what it costs
we'll let it go back to the original
author what I'll be very curious about
is whether or not any
other Studio would be willing to touch
it or
not uh that would be very curious to me
because there's a bunch that never would
Disney would not touch it with a 10-
foot pole um just because of how
radioactive the Creator is at this point
I think most major Studios probably
wouldn't at this point and most of the
smaller ones who either uh agree with
rolling don't care or believe the profit
is worth the hassle probably can't offer
her as much money as she's going to
want so I do think overall the property
is in a downward spiral I think they're
going to what's going to happen this is
my expectation and I could be
wrong but my expectation is they will do
a sequel to Hogwarts Legacy it will not
sell near nearly as well because it will
not be a significant improvement over
the first one and the first one sold
very well on on the back of being a
genuinely good so far as I'm aware uh
exploration of that world in with modern
tech that just didn't exist otherwise
but now we have it and just doing it
again um isn't going to get the same
returns but it's going to cost just as
much if not more so that's going to make
less and I expect that every season of a
Harry Potter TV show is going to get
less and less and less and less numbers
year-over year uh it'll gang Buster
season one that might hope for season
two and it's going to start dropping
after that and I think at the end of all
that with a sequel video game out that
isn't doing as well and watching the
numbers drop and like we won't know if
the numbers drop on the TV series unless
uh WB publishes that and generally they
don't they guard their streaming numbers
that's one of the many things that uh
the the unions are fighting over because
they hide their data which makes it very
easy for them
to
lie about how much people are
owed because they don't they won't tell
you what your viewing numbers are like
imagine if because I have analytics on
YouTube imagine if I knew how much
YouTube said I made and how much they
were willing to pay me every year but I
wasn't allowed to see what my view count
was if I wasn't allowed to see how many
views the video got that'd be messed up
because I'd have to take their word that
it was the amount I got paid maybe it
wasn't maybe it was more I don't know I
can't tell but anyway that turned into a
tangent Eric guess have you ever read
anything by tanith Lee I have
not the name does not ring an
immediate
Bell British fiction
writer excuse me Knight's Master the
birth grave death's Master deliriums
mistress delusions Master silver medal
lover I think red as blood I think I
might have shelved some of her books
back when I worked at a Barnes & Noble I
think that's the only reason I kind of
recognize some of these titles but no
I'm I'm not familiar and I have not uh I
have not read
her it's hard to watch The Crow knowing
what happened to Brandon Lee I mean it
adds a certain point to it like when I
watch that movie um the bit that that
gets me is when uh he gets injured it's
in the church and he's hiding behind a
Pew and
um the the cop Ernie Hudson comes up to
him you know when he's Hur and he says I
thought you were invincible and Brandon
Lee goes I
was I don't know something about that
moment with the context of what goes on
and what happened in real life that oh
that one hits me like a freight train
every damn
time with how desperate suties are to
squeeze Pennies From a Stone to the
point that I am Legend 2 is coming up oh
yeah I saw that we'll see if it actually
moves forward or
not uh remaking the crow kind of feels
as unnecessary is remaking RoboCop
unless they can do something new with it
see the thing is as bad as the RoboCop
remake was I think there was a reason to
try at least in theory
because the original RoboCop was
addressing a lot of very specific stuff
of the time and some of that stuff
Remains the case but also a lot of new
stuff has come into play especially in
terms of Technology with drones and
individual rights and privacy and you
could have actually done a remake of
Robocop to address the more recent
concerns and there there it the end
result was very unnecessary I don't
think the concept was necessary
necessarily doomed
though if you've seen the many thoughts
on secret of Kels and song of the sea
love them both secret of Kels is my
favorite movie from that studio song of
the SE is also very good everything
they've made is
good uh you may have a calling as a
therapist you have very good insight and
offer Sage comments oh thank you
homebody uh I I would be a crap
therapist
because um I get my notes screwed up and
I i' forget things from session to
session but I appreciate the
sentiment Supreme Omega do you feel the
success in Hollywood became franchise
driven and IP driven all about the
Blockbusters
um no because those are kinds of two
separate issues jaws and Star Wars are
kind of responsible for kicking off the
Blockbuster era where like we do these
big spectacle films that's what
Hollywood is that's what we do now
franchises and IP taking over everything
that kind of happened later and for a
long time Star Wars was a fluke for a
long time the franchise was the
star you know there were multiple
Terminator movies but really you were
just going to see an Arnold
schwarzeneger movie yeah there were
multiple Rocky and Rambo movies where
you're going to see a Sylvester Stallone
movie a Tom Cruz movie
the franchise driven nature of just the
property itself that didn't really start
solidifying into the shape that it
currently is until well into the 2000s
that's not the fault of Jaws in Star
Wars although they did kick open the
door for the Blockbuster era on the
summer blockbuster in
particular wouldn't be surprised if
rolling star is trying to start her own
Studio she's done weird stuff with her
money I mean she kind of does have she
has her own production company that that
handles the um the the the TV
adaptations of her um her mystery books
that apparent that nobody seems to
edit so she has she has a production
company that's I mean that's not the
same as having a studio in the sense of
like how Warner Brothers has a studio
she doesn't have those resources um by
the way another podcast support to the
Q&A I sent in so many questions they
decideed to do a whole episode
responding to me I believe
it um you you do ask interesting
questions you absolutely do
so no no shade there uh if the Harry
Potter show does happen hopefully not it
will um you know it'll play right into
the garbage IP TV model where fan
service is where the series starts and
ends which is I mean yes which is why I
expect interest is going to drop off
heavily after the second season at best
and possibly just after the first
because we know these
stories we've read
them and we've seen them like the thing
to remember about Game of Thrones um
forgetting how badly it ended for a
second most people hadn't read those
books so the stories for a huge SWA of
the audience even though they could have
read them the first five books anyways
at any point um those were
new Harry Potter isn't
new and not only is it not new in the
sense of people have been able to read
the books and the books have been super
insanely popular for a very long time I
mean there's also been a super insanely
popular adapt adaptation
already we all know this
story like really really what what what
is there to
do I
just I really do very sincerely believe
that the only reason it's happening is
because they do not know what else to do
with the property and it's not yet
unprofitable so they had to figure out
something favorite thing not Doctor Who
starring a Doctor Who actor or an actor
that played a companion you
like um and if it's the Air Zone
solution you can keep quiet you don't
have to admit it
um
uh honestly probably right now good
Omens which now gets to claim multiple
um Doctor Who uh like actual doctor
actors in it after the second season um
that's that's going to be my answer for
now I'm not going to call that
definitive
um
but yeah we we we'll go with that for
now I really need to see with nail and I
I've needed to see that for a while I
gota I gota I gotta watch that at some
point anyone else think Constantine 2 is
just dead in the water and WB doesn't
want to admit it I well I mean right now
they can't do anything with it because
the you know the writer and the actors
are are on strike but I think I don't
think they will admit it for as long as
counter Reeves continues to say he would
be up for doing it because he is such a
beloved figure that they will keep that
door open and hope to get there
uh I'm going to have to wrap it up soon
let me see if I can grab a few more of
these questions next month sees the
release of Magic the Gatherings Doctor
Who cards will you take a look at them
at all nope no intention CU virtually
everything that's going to be on there
I'm going to be like what is that like I
used to play Magic the Gathering but I
played Magic the Gathering like 20 years
ago and every time I like look at a card
now that's come out in the last 5 years
it's like got all these effects on it
I'm like I don't know what any of that
means I don't know what any of that does
so no I don't plan
to I was a member of your community back
when I was younger I don't know if you
remember my name back then was TV and
sin just popping in say hey hey Skipper
I yes I do remember
you I remember you thanks for stopping
in
hey to you
too did Jaws make you too scared to go
in the water
nope
uh made me feel amazing the day it
dropped I I get that
there the uh the relatively geeky
podcast I don't reply to everything that
they do but their shortbox showcase
series which is coming to an end
unfortunately but they they have they
have noted more than a few times when
they've done the feedback section that
and now let's get to beerus feedback
she's The Unofficial third member of the
podcast so I get
it all right yes I will hype Carolyn
just give me one quick moment here uh
have you ever seen the early 2000s Barb
B movies
nope uh fair enough there's now
double-sided cards and stick okay yeah
no I'm definitely not going to try and
figure that out bye have a good night
everyone in the chat as well you too Jen
don't feel you need to hold back on what
you think of adri I said what I thought
of
adrick okay
so tomorrow I will be streaming it'll be
more on Twitch it'll be more octopath
traveler it is going to be a short
stream because I have stuff going on in
the afternoon that I am going to have to
end the stream early in order to do so
be aware of that also tomorrow on the
main Channel I will have a video out
talking about shoy gotas coming out
which happened in L magazine recently so
that'll be
tomorrow Friday more um streaming on
Twitch I will have a video out about the
game potion craft at some point this
week and Saturday will be a video on
good omen season 2 and that'll be on the
main channel so that is what is coming
up and I hope uh everybody has a great
evening a great rest of the week um and
I will see you uh on which whichever of
those things you decide to
attend um so thank you very much please
remember that you are
beautiful you are
valued and you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
mavity